que
[Musique]
où
ce voeu des problèmes
je veux que tu galères de vie
mais bien
je veux que tu balances au visage des
orages des peines pour des nuits
mais
je veux qu'on ça prenne je veux partager
tes joies des immigrés
ton corps
vertige est témoin
ou rien
je
secours m
à tous et notre histoire sur le bras
met dans de beaux draps cité avec moi
c'est toi dans ce monde
vous
je
c'est tout
et je voudrais que ça dure longtemps
usée ma peau sur la tienne
bonjour j'oublierai tout jusqu'à mon nom
je saurai simplement que tu n'as que tu
es belle que tu es mienne je voudrais
que ça dure sentence
que je mets la raison n'atténue c'est un
peu cette envie de rêver tous les deux
commères
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour mon dieu c'était
[Musique]
évidence sourire ému ma carte chance je
veux condé comme condé crack en délire
compte ans jusqu'aux d'un mécénat
où
j'irai dans la russie table ou 120
toiles je pourrais vivre le
[Musique]
en froid
c'est toi dans ce plan de fou
je sais c'est tout
je voudrais que ça dure usée ma peau sur
la tienne
un jour j'oublierai tout jusqu'à
je sens rsa
que tu es là
tout est prêt
que des miettes faudrait que ça dure 100
ans
que sa mère
c'est un peu cette envie de rire
le
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour nos deux yeux
c'était
longtemps les émois possible la tienne
j'oublierai tout jusqu'à son sort n'est
simple
côté là que tes peines
santos
plus e mail
tél
cette nuit
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour nous tous les yeux
c'était
[Musique]
aux yeux
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]